well the house select committee
investigating the january 6 riot wants
to know who organized the attack with
particular focus on former president
trump there are others who are focused
on the still simmering question of who
participated in it and why they
participated were they motivated only by
the false idea of a stolen election or
was there something deeper something
that won't pass as quickly as a single
campaign cycle well researchers at the
university of chicago have been looking
into these questions and they find
evidence of a conflict here in america a
conflict smoldering underneath all the
other conflicts and it begins with a
single fact more than 90 percent of the
people arrested for the attack on the
capital were white and the key
characteristic according to the
researchers uniting these attackers was
not ideology or geography but in fact
race quote they come from counties where
the white share of the population is
declining fastest well earlier this year
you'll notice my winter coat in these
pictures we visited a place that has
already experienced a sudden demographic
change it's a city in pennsylvania where
white americans accustomed to being an
overwhelming majority are quite suddenly
not
we arrive in allentown pennsylvania one
day last winter and to us absolutely
nothing seems out of the ordinary but
talk to ed frack and he'll tell you
that's because we haven't lived through
the changes here my mother grew up a
couple blocks away
sixth in the liberty area and
it just
back then you could walk around you
could leave your doors unlocked as a kid
i mean allentown was amazing because
ed's friend gary iacocca also remembers
that older allentown and the non-stop
crowds that used to shuffle through the
hot dog shop his grandfather opened
after coming here from italy i will tell
you the original yankos was open at six
a.m in the morning and we closed at 1 30
at night and we were busy all day well
this was a blue blue-collar town third
shifts they would get off they'd come
down to yonkos they'd get a couple hot
dogs drink a beer and go home and while
that family business continues in other
locations the original yaakos is gone
closed after 82 years the problem is the
neighborhood began to change as other
little restaurants opened up
you know hispanic restaurants uh soul
food restaurants uh
asian restaurants that
became a little more competitive i
remember clearing it out it was
heartbreaking because you know
i grew up
sad very sad i'm kind of upset on how
some of this stuff has gone as for ed
frack by the time his mother passed away
in 2020 at 90 years old he says it had
been at least a decade since she felt at
home it was just a different kind of
culture people talked people said hello
shook your hand and now it's you know a
little bit different
crack says he often doesn't see the same
level of pride or consideration that's
allentown
what's changed is not only the culture
or economy but the people
in the 1970s allentown was 97 percent
white
by 2020 though the white share of the
population had plunged to 31 percent as
hispanic residents became what the local
paper calls a strong majority the men
women and children who come and just as
it took years for previous waves of
immigrants to be accepted into their
communities
there's a sense of tension here so just
to be clear there are white people in
allentown who think that the problem
with this street is all the non-white
people who have moved in
that's why the pride has declined that's
why the condition of the street has
declined
do i have that right yeah yeah those
people are out there yeah
definitely one of the more interesting
theories about
the riot and the capital on january 6th
is that the people
who went
the biggest predictor of whether they
would go
was whether their county had the loss of
the white population relative to
minorities
does that surprise you
no not really why not um
we had we had some folks right from here
ago
after our conversation right now you
know yes
i could see that more so than
than what i would have thought before
most of america not just allentown is
changing at least demographically
according to census data the number of
white americans dropped last decade
across 35 states and in three out of
four counties
in headlines you may have seen america
will no longer have a white majority by
2044. we're in an explosive moment in
america right now michelle norris has
been covering this long moment in
america for more than a decade reporting
in national geographic back in 2018 that
some white americans react anxiously and
angrily to a sense that their way of
life is under threat
people feel like something is being
snatched from them sometimes
and even though it's not something that
is tangible
community pride
a sense of of belonging a sense that
this is my town and we built it and now
it doesn't feel like it's mine anymore
it's not the one that they grew up in
and the irony is
for many of the immigrant families that
came there people were saying the same
thing about them
when they arrived so that idea of
something being snatched from them it
makes me think of
former president donald trump's campaign
slogan make america great again it's
nostalgic
well nostalgic can be sweet
and sometimes nostalgic can be
us the toxic is that toxicity can
sometimes tip into outright violence
something another allentown family the
manias worries about inside their corner
grocery store thankfully nothing has
happened but you can never put it past
anyone emily manaya came from the
dominican republic as a child and she
says she's got a theory about what's
driving all this tension white has
always been equal to superior on top and
so when you have such a long time coming
with that lifestyle with that mentality
all that like that notion um to just see
it like slip out of your fingers in like
just a few years or whatever it's like
wait a minute do you think allentown is
an example of the future of america 100
even those states where there's probably
no hispanics at all no black people they
will be seeing a lot of that in the next
few years so for someone who hears that
sentence and thinks uh-oh yeah even a
little bit
you say what
oh
i don't know
it wouldn't be very nice to say it on tv
or whatever um
suck it up
and it's it's going to happen that's it
so while things may feel different for
those living in allentown
our first impression was the right one
nothing about this
is out of the ordinary the country is
changing
and in some ways people are afraid
of change that has already arrived
it's already here
how bumpy of a ride are we informed it's
very bumpy i mean
put your seatbelt on it's going to be a
very
very
very bumpy ride
michelle norris is one of the best in
the country when it comes to talking
about these issues and explaining them
uh on the subject of putting your seat
belt on i mean the reason went to
pennsylvania is because it sent the
second highest number of rioters they
hailed from there oh wow on january 6th
and also almost every county has seen a
decline in the white population there
but again this is really a national
story most americans 80 about live in a
county where the white population has
declined and for most people that's fine
or it's welcome it's even something to
celebrate but there's a portion that the
university of chicago has identified for
whom it's very dangerous and one more
note i just want to shout out uh ed
frack and gary iacocca i appreciate them
talking with me they welcome the new
residents but they're in touch with this
part of town and part of their state
that maybe is less welcoming and not
comfortable with the change they say
these new folks are no different from
the germans and the italians who weren't
exactly welcome when they came right not
so long ago yeah and since the
quote-unquote discovery of america this
country has been built from change so
regardless of race religion
socio-economic class
that change around you looks like it's
up to us to adjust we all are in pursuit
of this american dream right roof over
our head clothes on our back food on the
table
and we want our kids to be raised in a
harmonious society
we have to accept what change is i once
heard something i'll leave everybody
with this change is inevitable growth is
optional and it's up to us to grow with
change you don't have to like love but
coexisting that's something we all can
do
yeah blame somebody else for your
problems and that's where the trouble
begins it's not going to be somebody
else's fault great piece yeah thank you
guys appreciate it all right you can
hear more of my conversation with
journalist michelle norris on today's
cbs morning's podcast you'll learn what
led her to create something very
interesting it's called the race card
project it invites people to distill
their thoughts about race their
experiences their observations into a
sentence of just six words in most years
most of the people responding are white
people interestingly enough